the disappearance of 22 year old gabby
patio quickly made national headlines
and it renewed a conversation about who
gets media attention in missing persons
cases critics say media coverage often
ignores people of color consider this
the black and missing foundation says
nearly 40 percent of cases involving
peace people of color but they rarely
make headlines we're joined now by the
foundation's co-founder and ceo derek
wilson good morning derica now derek
people of color they go missing but they
rarely get the headlines why do you
think this is
yes oftentimes when a person of color
goes missing especially when it's a
child they're labeled as a runaway
runaways are not getting their amber
alert they're not getting
that sense of urgency where people are
looking for them and when it comes to
missing men and women of color their
disappearance is oftentimes associated
with some sort of criminal activity so
again they're not receiving that urgency
and the attention as well now what's the
impact of this disparity because we can
only show what we know and oftentimes we
don't know what's going on on local
levels
well i think it's a combination first
and foremost we need law enforcement we
need them to be held accountable and
making sure that they're taking these
police reports we need the media to
share these cases and we need the
community to come forward we understand
that not every case is going to bubble
up to mainstream media we understand
that not every case is gonna make the
five and ten o'clock news cycle but less
is more less of one particular race and
more of everyone else that's missing
greater the chances of a reunion you
know we have we can name the natalie
holloway the the kaylee anthony the
lacey peterson the chandra levy but no
one can name one black or brown missing
person of color in the united states not
one so
gwen ifill the late gwen eiffel had a
phrase for what you're describing it
called it a missing white woman syndrome
can you explain that
yes um that uh term is actually uh
unless you're you know fairly attractive
white blonde hair blue eyes your stories
are just not sensational enough and and
these families they're desperate you
know over the past few weeks we've seen
the news coverage with gabby potito and
our hearts go out to the potito family
but there's a lot of gabby potito's in
the black and brown community these
families are hurting they're so
desperate to find out what happened and
they want to understand why is that case
any different from their missing loved
one because there is nothing worse than
not knowing not knowing if your loved
one is hurt if they're being mistreated
if they're cold if they're hungry if
they're going to walk through the front
door again
yeah and that that is the question derek
why is there case any different
i still don't understand why there is a
difference
can you really talk specifically about
why you think is it the media to blame
what do you think
i i really think that we need more
diversity in the newsroom you know the
decision makers don't look like us
and so you know we have to fight just to
get our stories out there you know our
lives are devalued when you know
families go to law enforcement to report
their loved ones missing and so if you
even go on the social media platforms
these families are desperate they're
trying to create their own way of
getting the stories out and sadly so
many uh families are being victimized
when they're creating their own flyers
they're putting their personal
information out there so they're being
scammed you know they're receiving these
calls these ransom calls we've had
families to lose their
entire savings you know we've had them
to lose their homes because they were
scammed out of it they are so vulnerable
now derek i see you wearing the hashtag
help us find us shirt now what can
people at home that are watching right
now asking themselves what can i do is
social media a good way to help get
these stories out
oh absolutely social media is a great
way to get these stories out we ask for
the community to demand change
you know with you know the media outlets
we need them you know more diversity we
need to hold law enforcement accountable
as well you know i was thinking back on
a case that's also
happening right now with daniel robinson
who's missing out of arizona you know he
was working when he went missing
you know leaving his job site and law
enforcement they're not really taking
the case as serious as they should um
you know when i spoke with the father
the other day you know he's saddened
because you know you're looking at the
television and you see that with gabby
potito's case they brought out the
drones the divers the four-wheelers
the list goes on and on and he's having
to create a gofundme just so he could
hire a private investigator and a search
team to look for his son who is a
geologist in arizona
yup i just heard about that story last
week listen i love the help us find us
because the media attention as we all
know makes a huge huge difference
absolutely thank you all for using your
platform to help us tell the story
thank you derek i think thank you for
coming and enlightening us a lot of
people need to hear your message today
and hopefully that's been delivered